please welcome Robert De Niro serve and
Anthony Hopkins Adrien Brody and Michael
Douglas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
the pitfalls of playing a historical
figure so familiar and so widely
interpreted are too numerous to mention
which is why but I viewed an amazement
the new life brought to Richard Nixon by
Frank Langella
minutes into frost/nixon the comparisons
to the real man and all other versions
slip away and we are drawn into the
inner life of a humbled fallen leader
still fighting to control how history
will view him Frank your work in this
film
against all odds is incomparable and I
salute you for that and Bravo
how did he do it how for so many years
that Sean Penn get all those jobs
playing straight men
being a movie star can get in the way of
acting but not for Sean Sean Penn the
actor loses himself in every role so we
can discover a man named Sam mystic
rivers Jimmy Markum the surfer dude
Spicoli a dead dead man walking and
Harvey Milk Sean brings
Shawn brings the same commitment to his
off-screen life you see it when he
campaigns for Human Rights respectfully
advises worldly leaders and gently
gently reasons with the paparazzi
tonight it's important to be a great
actor in life it's more important to be
a great human being that's my friend
Sean Penn
not that I'm a fan of being Google's but
if you google the resume of Richard
Jenkins you'll scroll across a career
that includes over sixty films in the
last 25 years
this is an actor with a vast repertoire
and in the visitor you're in the lead
Richard and you're you carry every scene
with an effortless and compelling
simplicity born of these only experience
can bring your unquestionably
recognizable but tonight Richard Jenkins
I'm happy that you get the recognition
Bravo
a Brad Pitt the leading man we all know
shows up about two-thirds of the way
through the movie The Curious Case of
Benjamin Button before that time we've
watched a wonderful performance by a
truly great great character actor and it
seems appropriate that this is the role
to bring you the third acknowledgment
Brad and apart from the wonderful
trickery and magical technology employed
in Benjamin Button is a fully realized
creation thanks to the skills of a
brilliant actor I've had the pleasure to
work with had to know well and
magnificent job my friend great
brilliant work
[Music]
Randy the RAM Robinson the wrestler gets
a second shop back in the ring and back
in his life but why do we care for a
bleach-blonde battered bruiser
well there's one very good reason Mickey
Rourke
only a fiercely honest actor could be so
effective as a guy who hasn't had it
easy but has clearly learned the value
of a chance at redemption we're better
off having you in the ring welcome back
the returning champ
Nikki war
and the Oscar goes to Sean Penn
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
you commie homo loving sons of guns I I
did I did not expect this but I and and
I wanted to be very clear that I do know
how hard I make it to appreciate me
often but I I am touched by the
appreciation and I and I hope for it
enough that I did want to scribble down
so I had the names in case you were
coming home Oh loving sons of guns and
so I I wanted to thank my best friend
SATA Matt sazabi my circle of longtime
support mara brian beary and Bob the
great Cleve Jones our wonderful writer
Lance Black produces Bruce cone and Dan
Jenks and and particularly as all as
actors know our director either has the
patience talent and restraint to to
grant us a voice or they don't and it
goes from the beginning of the meeting
to through the cutting room and there is
no finer hands to be in the Gus Van Sant
finally for those two last finally for
those who who saw the signs of hatred as
our cars drove in tonight and I think
that it is a good time for those who
voted for the ban against gay marriage
to sit and reflect and anticipate their
great shame and the shame and their
grandchildren's eyes if they continue
that way of support we've got to have
equal rights for everyone
and there are and there were these last
two things I I'm very very proud to live
in a country that is willing to Anna let
elect an elegant man president and a
country and a country who for all its
toughness creates courageous artists and
this is in great due respect to all the
nominees but create a courageous artists
who despite a sensitivity that sometimes
has brought enormous challenge Mickey
Rourke rises again and he is my brother
thank you all very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]